MAVERICKS SUNDAY  TO ALITY.
>> Derek: IT'S AN
I'VE BEEN SHOOK LIKE  CHERRY ON.
THAT'S A BIGGER PLAYER.
THE NEW PLAYERS.
HAVE HIS
LEGS RIGHT NOW.
SURE, HE'S BEEN LEFT, RIGHT.NSE.
ONCE AGAIN.
DALLAS LOOKING TO DRIVE IT.
KLAY THOMPSON
IT WAS SLOW.
ON HIM, THE WARRIORS DO. ARKANS.
LUKA GOT AROUND CURRY.
A LOTFENSIVELY.
NOT MUCH LUCK WITH THAT ONE
EITHER.
TREY ON THE RUN
>> 15-11, CHICUE.
12.1.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS HE ER.
DOES NOT WANT TO RISK
REINJURING.
HE IS BEENL A PROBLEM.
THE THREE-POINTER IS GOOD HERE.
VUCEVIC.
>> THAT IS A BIG THREE.
>> 108-102.
THE BULLS, 14th PLAY  AND TWO
DAYS OF REST.
HAWKS AND D BEEN HUGE IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER. DEFENDING.MOKES
ONE.
>> Brian: YEAH.
GUARD.
>> Stan: WOW.
I DOMINANT THIRD QUARTER. FORCI.
>> Brian:
HE IS BEING ARE A
TOUGH TEAM TO COME BACK FROM AND
THAT IS A BIG STORY.
GOING TO B
INTERESTING TO SEE IF DOUBLE.
>> Brian: STOPS AN SERIES.
>> Brian: TATUM.
BANE HE DROVE OPPOSITE
OF THE DOUBLE-TEAM COMING AND
GOT ALL THE WAY TO THE
FIRST LET'S GET INTO THE STEVEN
ADAMS' SITUATION.
STEVEN ADAMS JUSTT KNOW THE DEF
LEADS TO EASY OFFENSE AND THAT
IS WHY THEY STEPPEDN THE
NBA.
>> Brian: BOSTON, NUMBER ONE
THEIS TO TATUM.
>> Stan: G G 3 FROM THREE-POINT.
.
COACH, WE SAW THIS TUESDAY. FOR.
MORANT.
TATUM KNOCKS IT REBOUND.
SECOND CHANCE HERE FOR THE  Bri.
HORFORD SECURES.
PASS BY FOR BO.
LOOKING FOR TATUM HERE.
HE FOUOU IS 8 FOR 16 SINCE.
HE HAS 24 NOW. TON OF FOURTH
QUARTER LEADS EARLY IN
SMART GOT ANKLE THREE MINUTES
INTO THE GAME ON TUESDAY.
MORANT.
WE HAVE A WHISTLE AND WILL A
BLOCKSEASON FOR
BROOKLYN.
HIS NINTH START IN A ROW.
, THINKING DRUMMOND. GUYS
HE IS 3 OF 3
BROOKLYN.
HERRO HITS GOOD POSITION. THAT
BEFO,
LOOK THE
DELIVERS, ONCE AGAIN,